in the icy waters of Antarctica
scientists use a method unchanged in a
hundred years to catch and study
plankton but in their fine mesh net they
now also find a 21st century threat I
think we might have a surprise in here
there's something bright green it's hard
plastic perhaps part of a bottle cap
slowly degrading as it drifts on the
current in the most isolated and
pristine place on the planet it's not
only where lots of people of it's in
remote pristine places it gets
everywhere with global currents ocean
currents get distributed and yeah let's
can find it even here in such remote
places in Arctic a british antarctic
survey ship the James Clark Ross is a
floating laboratory onboard is another
scientist trying to quantify for the
first time the amount of micro plastic
in the fjords it's there in every liter
of seawater but she carefully filters
under the microscope there are even more
lots more plastic than I was expecting
to see so far it's easily in the
hundreds per litre of water which is
very sad because the locations were
looking at our new habitats they're
essentially pristine untouched most of
the place throughout are actually on the
survey so you wouldn't expect to see a
bunch of human influence but so far
they're definitely husband plastic is
rapidly increasing in the South Atlantic
and scientists believe it's coming
Antarctica's way and tucked occurs
marine creatures like this tiny
crustacean are already having to deal
with rapid climate change warming seas
disappearing sea ice and strengthening
winds but the appearance of so much
plastic so quickly is putting them under
new stress the question is if it gets
into the food chain can they cope
this marine ecologist says Coldwater
creatures may take three weeks to finish
a meal so it has to be nutritious if
most of that meal is full up of little
plastic fragments tiny tiny micro
plastics and even smaller then they've
wasted most of that time processing the
meal for something that not only isn't
going to give them anything but worse
still it fills up their stomach so
they've got less to put in next time so
really quite bad this is the last wild
place on the planet barely touched by
humans but is no longer remote enough to
escape the plastic tide Tamas more Sky
News Antarctica